welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and did Captain Marvel Carol
Danvers commit a war crime against the
cre in the Marvels spoiler warning for
the Marvel's film but this movie reveals
that the plot of the cre civilization
led by General darbin is to open portals
to siphon air water and sunlight from
other worlds to save their own dying
home planet of Hala following the
depletion of their resources after
Captain Marvel dropped down on Hala with
no warning 30 years prior and destroyed
the cre Supreme intelligence leaving
them with no government to rule in its
place resulting in decades of Civil War
and earning her the nickname of the
annihilator thank you to boxu for
sponsoring this video more on their
tasty offerings later late in the movie
Carol tells Monica and Camala on the
grassland Planet quote the cre had been
ruled by an AI from Millennia that led
them into a war I thought that the only
way to stop them was to destroy it but I
just made it worse I'm the reason why
the Civil War started in the first place
I'm the reason they couldn't breathe the
air that's how I got the name the
annihilator Monica asks is that why you
never came back and Carol responds I
thought if I fixed it then I could come
home so Carol's guilt was for me one of
the most fascinating aspects of the
Marvel's film while the MCU has dealt
with the legal and ethical consequences
of the Avengers actions before like the
sovia Accords or Peter Parker's drama
with the dodc and Spider-Man no way home
Marvel went way further with Carol than
I think they even realized so we need to
discuss what the cre Supreme
intelligence was the timeline of Carol's
actions with the cre and their impact
what constitutes a war crime and whether
Carol's actions were truly Justified
spoiler warning I think they were but
this movie didn't do enough to explain
why they were what is the cre Supreme
intellig in the comics the cre Supreme
intelligence was created over a million
years ago composed of the brains of the
greatest cre thinkers philosophers
scientists leaders those brains removed
upon their deaths and then assimilated
into a supercomputer to live on as a
collective AI that runs all aspects of
cre civilization the cre race had really
stopped evolving so the Supreme
intelligence was designed in part to
ensure the continuation of the race and
all the good and bad parts of it you
know like scroll genocide now the
Supreme intelligence as it was
introduced in the 2019 Captain Marvel
film was mysterious AI that took the
form of whoever the witnesser most
admires it was contained in a building
on the planet Hala for Carol it took the
form of Dr Wendy Lawson the cre
scientist she once served in Project
Pegasus now the production designer the
2019 Captain Marvel film Andy Nicholson
said that this comic book depiction was
originally planned to be seen in the
2019 film The Moment Carol pulled out
her proton inhibitor the big green head
would have risen from a pool in the back
of this chamber that comic accuracy
appears now in the Marvels it's a large
green face Four Eyes same kind of
circuitry running in and out of what
would that circuitry be connected to if
not the brains of the cre Einstein I
just think it's safe to say that Carol
unplugged the brains of the cre best and
brightest did Carol know she was doing
that the 2019 film suggested that the
Supreme intelligence was a mysterious
entity but for the cre Society to trust
its wisdom they must know it is based on
their aristotles their gandhis their
Einstein they know it's important for
cre Society to function now you could
get into the metaphysical debate of are
those disembodied brains still alive
well let's ask Vision who who's composed
of adamantium infused living tissue and
a soul that is derived from the Mind
Stone and from Jarvis mixed with a tap
of Moler lightning look if the ship of
thesias argument applies to the
sentience and consciousness of vision
and of white Vision then it certainly
applies to the cre brain matter that
powers the Supreme intelligence so let's
talk about Carol's timeline with the
cree the 2019 Captain Marvel film ended
in 1995 with Carol leaving Earth
supposedly to help the squirrel of
refugees find a new home planet
previously that seemed to be part of
Marvel's justification for why Carol was
missing from the events of the MCU and
it's kind of what Carol snapped at Ro in
endgame hey new girl everybody in this
room is about that Superhero life and if
you don't mind my asking where the hell
have you been all this time there are a
lot of other planets in the universe and
unfortunately they didn't have you guys
but now we know that Carol was actually
busy putting out all the fires she
caused by toppling the universe's
biggest superpower the Creed because in
1995 right after Captain Marvel ended
Carol went directly to Hala she left
whatever she was doing with the Scrolls
and said you know what I'll be right
back I want to go nuke this place and we
know it was the same year of 1995
because Dar Ben tells the cre on Hala in
this movie that she has been fighting
with them for quote 30 years the Marvels
takes place in the year 2025 30 years
earlier would be 1995 so Carol when she
was a lot younger unilaterally toppled a
government of a major Intergalactic
superpower wiping out their entire
executive legislative and judicial
branch with nothing in place to take
over in its dead this power vacuum
caused the K civilization to fall into
Civil War their natural resources to be
depleted rulers Darin called Heretics
coming into power and eventually darban
herself finding the quantum bands to
risk the destruction of SpaceTime to
save them now you can say that's not all
the fault of the destruction of the
Korea Supreme intelligence holla star is
dying that's just bad luck in nature
yeah entanglement is a big component of
what makes the Marvels fun and you can
keep that fun going by entangling
snacking and surprise with bxu bxu is a
premium Japanese snack box that works
with family businesses all over Japan to
deliver a new theme of authentic
Japanese snacks every month and honestly
it makes a great gift fun snacks that
you usually have to travel to try people
love it and Beyond the snacks each box
Su comes with a booklet that teaches you
all about the theme and where the snacks
come from so that you can have a deeper
appreciation for what it is you're
munching on the first box of any boxy
subscription is the seasons of Japan
after that you receive a new theme every
month with curated seasonal snacks one
of my favorite things for these is a
white strawberry it's so sweet and the
strawberries infused with white
chocolate to just make like oh my God
it's Heaven it's a bite of heaven I'm
telling you but they also have these
smoky radish chips which compared with
the the sweet white chocolate strawberry
this just makes for a nice Smoky
something
something oh yeah o so good so good both
I and the new Rockstar's office have
been receiving these boxes for ages we
love them so if you want to try boxu and
support the channel click the link in
the description and use code rockstars
to get $15 off your order now you can
ask why wouldn't a race of interstellar
Travelers just relocate to a new planet
like the scroll and the asgardians have
had to do ask people who live in flood
PL and refused to evacuate hurricanes so
every time the cre have shown up in the
MCU like in Guardians of the Galaxy when
Ronin was running a muuk and they signed
a treaty with xandar and Nova Prime
called them for shutting down a
conference call a bit too early all that
time the cre had been dealing with
internal political Strife their society
has been on the brink now let's talk
about what a war crime is by its
definition you can actually read the
United Nations Rome statute of the
international criminal court article 8
on war crimes detailing various actions
that fall within that definition that
include section B subset 4 or
intentionally launching an attack in the
knowledge that such attack will cause an
incidental loss of life or injury to
civilians or damage to civilian objects
or widespread long-term and severe
damage to the natural environment which
would be clearly excessive in relation
to the concrete and direct overall
military Advantage anticipated now yeah
you're just going to say Captain Marvel
is madeup character she's not in our
jurisdiction and that the Geneva
conventions don't apply to space but her
rank of Captain comes from the United
States Air Force and these are the
values and EIC iCal standards with which
she was trained Earth was not at war
with Hala in 1995 you could say that
Ronin and yon rog's bombardment amounted
to enact War but Carol repelled that
attack the cre backed off Earth was no
longer facing an existential threat and
the United Nations or World Government
powers were never really notified of
what happened and what Carol did in
response was to destroy far more than a
military Target it disrupted all aspects
of civilian life as well so much so that
Carol spent 30 years trying to put out
those fires she clearly felt pretty
guilty over it so ultimately work
Carol's actions Justified well Carol's
motives for destroying the Supreme
intelligence in 1995 were likely one of
three things one ronin's attack on Earth
two the cre brainwashing Carol and using
her as a weapon and three the C's
ongoing genocide of the Scrolls if it
was just to retaliate ver ronin's attack
no I don't think it was justified Ronin
had backed off by retaliating that way
Carol was opening a can of worms to
geopolitics across the Galaxy and that
is a price that she paid for years if it
was to retaliate for her own
brainwashing yeah I think we'd all agree
that would be too selfish of a motive
and she's still pay paying that price
too she's still trying to clear her head
of all that brainwashing but the third
justification to protect the Scrolls
because the cre were at war with the
scroll Empire and they had already
committed plenty of their own war crimes
against scroll civilians if Carol
annihilated the Supreme intelligence as
a last resort to save the lives of all
the srel civilians then yes her actions
would be justified now the Marvel's film
just did not do enough to establish
Carol's relationship with the squirrels
in the years after the Captain Marvel
film like if Carol was trying to find
the scrs a new home world but the cre
Empire Ed by the Supreme intelligence
continued to assault them and Tred to
kill all the squirrel refugees as a last
resort to protect those Scrolls Carol
would totally be justified in
annihilating the Supreme intelligence
but because this film just doesn't make
time for this much of the backstory and
Carol just kind of says the Supreme
intelligence led the Kore into a war and
doesn't say her actions were to protect
the Scrolls and even coldly snaps at
Camala to leave scroll refugees behind
to suffocate on tarx we just kind of
leave this film not really knowing how
she feels about the Scrolls and the
Scrolls seem really pissed off at Carol
so is Carol Danver a war criminal
criminal I don't think so but without
evidence on screen in this film any
audience watching this thinking about it
for more than 10 seconds probably going
to say you know what the jury still out
but I want to know what you think in the
comments and you know what let's be
simple this is not Carol's fault it is
the studio that has developed and
written this character please support us
with this OB inspired we're all going to
die shirt at nerd. shop which is what
all the brains in thec Supreme
intelligence screamed when they saw
Carol follow me on all social platforms
at eav subscribe to all three channels
in the new Rockstar Network thanks for
watching I'll see you next time
bye
[Music]